ان كنت
افعدونالدو جيبولي الميه ويجوا لعندي
ولا وعد ههه
راحوا اولاده
كلمات قليله قد لا تختزل حجم معاناه هذه
السيده التي وجدت نفسها بين ليله وضحاها
وحيده بعدما خسرت من كانوا يسندون ظهرها
ويعينونها على عاديات الزمان
لحظه لم تتجاوز الدقيقه كانت كافيه لتجعل
هذه السيده تعيش ماساه حقيقيه اصابه
ابنيها ووفاه احفادها حتى منزلها لم يتبقى
منه سوى الانقاض التي جلست تبكي عليها
حسره وحزنا على قساوه المقاله اولادي
وانا مستاجر اللي تحت غادي انا والختيار
مستاجرين اللي ما عندي بنت عشقه قاعدين ما
شفت
مقعدوني قالوا لي البنيه يا ولادك
جيت
[ضحك]
ال ذهب بخمسه من احفادها وادى الى اصابات
بليغه بابنها
والاثنين
واحد مكسور ظهره ووعد مقزوله رقبته
[موسيقى]
ترفض مغادره المكان فاين لها ان تذهب ومن
عاشت لاجلهم لسنوات التهمهم الزلزال
والدمار بدي اتفرج
عشان اشوف دوري قبل ما يشيلوه كل امنيتها
الان ايجاد جفاميل المفقودين تحت الانقاض
والقاء نظره وداع اخيرا لن تواسيها حجم
الماساه